Hi, this is Josh Lowensohn with CNET.com...
...here at Samsung's post keynote demo of Youm.
This is a flexible display technology that's going to be in tablets, smartphones...
...and all sorts of new devices that Samsung hopes the companies are gonna make.
So let me show you what's cool about this.
The display can actually wrap around.
So on these two reference designs for basically concepts,...
...you get a display that wraps around the side.
Here it's on the bottom, and over here it's actually on the side of the device.
And what this lets you do is see a display or a notification or some sort of message...
...without actually having to open up the device or see it.
Samsung's example is that you can have it on a table...
...and flat and still see that kind of stuff.
So they kind of envision some products...
...that wrap around like binders or bifold wallets...
...and still have all your displays going.
So there's no price or release date on this yet,...
...but Samsung says it intends to ship into its partners in the future.
So again, this is a first look at Youm, Samsung's new flexible technology.
I'm Josh Lowensohn for CNET.com